who wins in a chess boxing match between  you and Magnus probably Magnus just  because he's he's taller than me I think  also reach he's taller is more reach  yeah but I I think he I think he would  win question from Reddit in what sport  do you think you can beat Magnus 10 out  of 10 times I think I could beat Magnus  10 out of 10 times in tennis I mean I  took lessons for eight years I I try to  go out and hit two or three times every  week I I think I could beat him in 10 to  7 out of ten backhand forehand what's  your what's what's your style of tennis  play I wish I was taller because I  really like trying to come into the net  I like I like falling a lot  um but I am no Rod Rod Laver I know and  Rod Laver was very short but he was able  to make it work like 50 60 years ago I  really like bowling but I'm a little bit  too short so I I kind of have to stay  back and and I mean I normally hit like  I try to hit hard forehands and I try to  slice uh slice or two hand backhand